so despite whatever you think about the
movie thor love and thunder to me this
is the weirdest thing i noticed about
this film it's a choice i just don't
understand why they did it i talked
about it during our 3011 thunder live
stream but i'm not gonna do any spoilers
here for you guys but first i want to
see if you guys notice it it happened so
early on in the movie earlier on the
film christian bale's gore is talking
with a certain character and they keep
cutting back and forth to this one shot
in one particular shot when they cut
back they do something weird with the
shot and i just don't understand why
they did it let me see if you guys
noticed that so here's the shot
and here's where they cut back to it
did you guys notice it it's so bizarre i
don't know why they did it but there's
something that's always distracting me
about christian bale and i'm sure
there's things about it online is that
he's got that mole right here when i saw
the dark knight ten times on imax and
every time i watch on imax i just always
stare at that mole of it he's like one
of my all-time favorite actors with that
damn mole i'm always looking at that
mole because it's consistent with every
one of his characters so when watching
this scene both times i watch this film
i noticed that he has his mole where it
normally is but in this one particular
shot for some reason they just flipped
it and his mole is on the other side and
i have no idea why they decided to flip
this shot it makes no sense to me and it
just distracts me as the man who's
always looking at christian males mold
did you guys notice this mole mole mole
[Music]